dr thomas aßmann der wird mir jetzt die
dringendsten fragen zu diesen mutierten
corona virus beantworten erstmal schön
dass sie sich die zeit nehmen
sie können sich sicherlich vorstellen
dass so eine nachricht jetzt vor
weihnachten nicht gerade ganz so toll
bei den leuten ankommt vielleicht können
sie für uns zuerst einordnen dieses
mutierte corona die russen was ist das
und wie wirkt das also man muss man
natürlich sagen das ist wirklich ein
sehr unterschiedliches
weihnachtsgeschenk was ist der virus da
reinbringen und die briten praktisch zur
erforschung drexhage treibt was ist
passiert
der virus selber das wissen wir fahrer
als viren bzw der wir selber mutiert das
heißt die zelle fällt bzw
die oberfläche verändert sich das heißt
aber da kann sich gut verändern das
heißt dann nicht mehr so ansteckend ist
und nicht mehr so gefährlich kann sich
aber auch in die richtung verändern dass
er gefährlicher wird einmal oder aber
auch anstecken das bedeutet anstecke
damit dass sich besser an die
körperzellen des menschen andocken kann
und sand sein wie sein genug seine erna
in den virus in den in die zelle hinein
geben kann und dadurch praktisch diese
ansteckung und führt und bei dieser
variante die wir dann in england
festzustellen haben scheint es dass der
virus der dort herrscht wesentlich
schneller leute krank machen kann
ansteckender ist und das ist echt
gefährlich da muss man aufpassen dass
uns der views nicht rechts überholt also
deswegen ist die impfung wirklich
wichtig dass wir das machen und wir
müssen uns auch überlegen wie vor
einigen kollegen gesagt haben ob wir
nicht bei bestimmten gruppen mit
zwangsimpfung machen damit wir nicht
rechts überholt werden von groß weil 70
prozent mehr ansteckung das ist eine
enorme steigerung und auch das macht die
ganze sache sehr sehr gefährlich jetzt
haben sie gerade gesagt 70 prozent mehr
ansteckend ich als nicht biologe musste
jetzt noch mal nachhaken was heißt dass
und wie wird so was gemessen
beziehungsweise wir tragen ja alle maßen
und halten abstand sind das dann auch
die maßnahmen die immer noch gelten ja
ganz klar erstmal ein jahr die show
maßnahmen müssten weiterhin gemacht
werden das heißt abstand halten ja
regeln und wirklich konsequent
durchziehen und jeder letzte das noch
nicht verstanden hat zeigt dass der
virus mit dem ist nicht so vorhanden
der will uns krank machen wer will sich
vermehren und da kann man keine
koexistenz machen da kann man sich nur
verschütten und den bekämpfen und das
können wir nur dadurch dass wir diese
haarigen unbedingt einhalten
70 prozent mehr bedeutet wenn sie jetzt
bei 100 infizierten
menschen noch mal 200 200 infizierte
hätten oder der würde jetzt 200 menschen
anderer infizierten noch gesund sind
würde wenn 100 leute diesen neuen
violetten nicht mehr 2 100 sondern dann
noch
jahrhundert einstecken können
und das bedeutet natürlich dass dann der
wert also die revolutionszeit natürlich
auch nach oben gehen würde
und da würden das würde zwangsweise zu
noch mehr einschränkungen führen wenn
sich diese virus weiter verbreiten
könnte all das wegen ist diese ein
starkes flugverkehrs und diese aktion
gewechselt glaube ich die einzige
alternative die wir zurzeit haben und
man muss wirklich gucken dass wir sie
ganz schnell mit den impfungen anpassen
am besten vor gestern als heute jetzt wo
sie noch mal ganz kurz an der stelle
nach hagen wenn sie sagen man steckt
sich leichter an heißt das auch dass das
virus an sich gefährlicher ist für den
menschen also noch gefährlicher als das
jetzige corona virus also so wie wir das
jetzt aus der presse beziehungsweise aus
den kollegen aus england erfahren haben
soll denn nicht gefährlicher sein
also mir reicht das schon so wieder
jetzt ist also der muss nicht nur
einpacken schlimmer werden damit er das
chaos weiter verstärkt und das problem
ist einfach er ist genauso gefährlich
genau so alt genauso krankheitserregern
und auch tödlich wie der alltag nur der
ist wesentlich ansteckender und das ist
halt gefährlich wenn sich einfach
vielleicht mal so vor wenn sie ein feuer
machen mit diesel
es dauert ein bisschen länger bis sie im
plan temperatur ist wenn sie mit super
sprit daher ist die explosion viel
gewaltiger beides sind kraftstoffe aber
die qualität ist um ein anderer und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt aufpassen dass
dieser virus uns nicht masse muss um die
ohren schlägt jetzt haben wir schon ein
paar mal angesprochen das thema impfen
in deutschland sollte dabei losgehen
jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage
wirkt diese impfung auch gegen das
mutierte virus so wie es aussieht ja
gott sei dank der virus beziehungsweise
bei diesem impfstoff und ist ja so dass
er gegen diese anzug seines also die
oberflächenstruktur des virus angeht und
es scheint so dass dieses zeigt sich
jetzt nicht wesentlich verändert haben
so dass die antikörper die der impfstoff
bei uns
zur produktion bringt auch da wirksam
sein könnte ja beziehungsweise wirksam
ist
wir haben gott sei dank noch kein
hinweis dass der impfstoff nicht werden
könnte wir müssen aber natürlich sagen
wir wissen nicht wie das in 234 modern
sein wird die größere hoffnung
beziehungsweise da ist aber auch
gott sei durch ein bisschen licht am
ende des tunnels dass dieser mr
im stoff auch sehr schnell wieder
angepasst werden kann
also wir müssen jetzt gucken wer hat den
längeren atem wir oder der videos ich
hoffe natürlich bier
das heißt wenn ich das jetzt mal ganz
kurz zusammenfassen darf dass hier
sozusagen jetzt aufpassen müssen dass
wird die impfung schnell durchziehen und
dass wir dann natürlich auch gucken
müssen wie verändert sich das virus
damit wenn ich in einen teufelskreis
kommen richtig exakt ganz genau richtig
also der der das problem ist dieser
blöde virus will uns reinlegen und die
müssen aufpassen dass der uns nicht
reinigt das ist jetzt wirklich so ein
wettkampf
ja wer ist schneller wer hat den
längeren atem und wer haut den anderen
schließlich einen auf die mütze
ja und dann muss man ganz klar sagen da
müssen wir wirklich dicht bei dicht
bleiben wie verändert sich der virus und
so weiter
da habe ich aber großes vertrauen gerade
auch unsere wissenschaftler europaweit
jedoch da sehr fit sind und sich den
genau angucken und auch genau
nachvollziehen wo geht die reise hin wie
verändert er sich was wir natürlich
machen müssen ist ein rechtzeitiges
waren system zu etablieren das mögliche
veränderungen des virus aufzeigt problem
war so wie ich gelesen habe dass der
virus schon teilweise oktober november
in england unterwegs war dass das ja
aber jetzt erst vor kurzem a verein zwei
wochen thematisiert worden ist und das
muss natürlich schneller passieren
herr doktor assmann vielen vielen dank
für ihre einordnung an dieser stelle
recht herzlichen dank wir sind bild und
wir liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren